do you think that President Obama got
the right message out tonight following
this unexpected and serious incident of
the shooting down of the Russian jet by
turkey I think he did I think the real
message today with solidarity and
cooperation among all of us in the West
against Isis and not appearing fluttered
or scared by this incident between
Turkey and Russia Russia and Turkey part
of the West well Russia is not i mean
the Turks are part of NATO so they were
certainly within their rights and
shooting down this plane I think there
are that and I think that we need to
express solidarity with them I think we
should not be you know acting as if
we're terrified now World War 3 do you
think there is a need to try and work
more with the Russians in spite of
Ukraine in spite of the bellicose toner
President Putin if this Isis priority is
to be sorted out well only if Isis is
their priority to as you know much of
the bombing they've done in Syria has
been of Syrian rebels not of Isis
they've done some but not as much as the
Western countries have done and I think
it's reasonable to think that they may
be in there more to preserve Assad now
both president Hollande and President
Obama said today really quite clearly
Assad has to go Assad is part of the
problem not part of the solution Assad
is a kind of recruiting for Isis with
the way he's murdering Sunnis so I think
the the message today was that there
will be limits on the cooperation with
Russia but that does need to be more
coordination to avoid a repetition of
instance like this right there but thats
coordination really just to deconflict
where there are flights although you
know the deconfliction is supposed to be
over Syria this Russian plane appeared
to be over Turkey where it wasn't
supposed to be at all and there is a
problem that Russia pays to have been
targeting Turkmens
ethnic Turks who are fighting is but who
are also fighting Assad who they want to
preserve yeah that's the problem with
the Russian involvement here I mean they
are trying to preserve Assad we are not
and I think it's the British view the
French view the American view that he's
got to go that that there will never be
any kind of peace in Syria while he is
ruling it after having killed so many
Sunnis who are the majority in Syria
does it matter in your view if Britain
takes away its block on taking part in
military operations in Syria is that
would that be an important development I
think so I you know I think the more
solidarity there is in Europe between
Europe in the u.s. within NATO I think
we are trying here to show a united
front and it's very it just doesn't work
the Americans to do that without British
participation maybe it's just a
tradition but we're used to having the
British with us and of course there's
just the previous spoke by the house of
commons two years ago against military
action in syria had a very serious
diplomatic and military impact it really
did and we're used to the special
relationship and we're used to working
with the UK and it frankly is a little
bit odd today you know for all of us who
remember 10 years ago the French being
completely out of the involvement in
Iraq and Afghanistan while we've been
doing this now for over a decade it's
odd to see a French be gung-ho it's nice
but it would be a lot better if we were
all in this together and it would be a
step toward reestablishing something
that a lot of people in Washington do
remember well and do value which is the
special relationship with UK what what
about Turkey and handling turkey
obviously politics there are very
volatile turkey is part of the wider
Sunni community
can it be relied on well you know
everyone has it has been a problem on
many issues I think it can be relied
upon you know to protect its own
interests and it happens that those
interests are largely in consonance with
ours at this point that is they want
Assad out they want a Sunni government
they don't know to what and more
refugees so if they just probably know
their national interests here which
happened to include making sure the
Russian planes can't at will overfly
Turkey I think we're going to be okay i
think their interests and ours are
aligned do you think there is a
fundamental problem as someone suggested
that the sunnis including Saudi Arabia
in the end are part of a broader
ideological alliance if you like with is
well I think the Saudis the Emiratis in
particular recoveries you know I've been
looking for anybody who would fight Iran
Hezbollah and the Assad regime and we
haven't given them a lot of help with
the more reasonable and moderate Sunni
rebels so I think if we step it up
France the u.s. hopefully the UK then I
think we will be able better to control
which groups in Syria they're backing
Callum's